Here's a good analogy about
government type thing.
So your schools,
there's always bullies and bullies
are aggressive kids who aren't really
inclined to play by the rules.
So they're aggressive and
they're not very conscientious.
And so they're kind of predatory and
they'll prey on other kids if given the
opportunity.
Okay,
so how do you stop that?
Well,
you don't go around feeling sorry for
the bullies because that doesn't work and
they don't have low self esteem.
They have high self esteem.
And the way that you deal with always
is you have parents or teachers watching
the school yard.
Every time I kid bully someone else,
you stopped them.
Now you don't throw them
in a cell for 10 years.
You just stop what they're doing
from having the desired outcome.
And then bullying goes away.
Now this has been demonstrated by
a guy in Scandinavia called Dan.
Oh yes,
he's done.
He's reduced bullying in the Scandinavian
countries by 50% and the way he's done
that is by ensuring that in school yards,
bullies get caught.
Not that they get punished now.
So translate that into political policy.
Concern is always argued that
you should be hard on crime.
Criminals crack down on crime.
It's like,
yes,
but their way they do it is by saying,
well,
let's have more extensive sentences.
That's the wrong approach.
The right approach is to decrease the
probability that the crime will be
successfully undertaken.
So you have to decrease the success rate
of the crime rather than increase the
punishment.
And that actually works.
There's,
so for example,
when they put drug addicts on,
uh,
tight observation schedule and have a
certain punishment associated with failing
a drug test that the drug
users who are on parole,
they stopped,
they stopped using drugs
because they know they're,
they're not going get away with it,
period.
So part of the role of the government is
to ensure that rule breakers do not get
away with it.
And that's also part of the role.
The citizenry Aa,
you shouldn't break
rules because if you do,
you contribute to the likelihood that
everything will fall apart and be,
you shouldn't let other people around
you get away with breaking rules.
So that's the role of government.
And that's not all,
but that's a big part of it.